yo  help me understand uh what is the love  relationship between the bay area and  detroit it's always been a thing  yeah it's been before me you know it  seemed like it's been since the  beginning of the time  but a lot of detroit dudes used to go to  get uh get money get  yeah so i think the lingo and the and  the culture kind of  you know transfer game like that so we  always been like related like cousins  yeah it feels like it's the detroit has  so much in common like  especially you know like you said like  just there's just always  sonically it just feels like y'all are  in the same pocket kind of when it comes  to just the culture and  yeah like i grew up on the street lords  there was a big  big group in detroit and they used to  have like be legit  too short e40 all of them on the album  so it was like  [ __ ] we started listening to them just  off of that right right right  so you know and sound sound the same